nader on george george  it's inside finds moore's extra pass but  to him corner three  that's good ten straight points by the  clippers  and the suns need timeout and i thought  paul george got away with a push-off  to gain space on the pass but big-time  shot by batoon  clip has climbed back into the ball game  little shoved by  paul george doesn't get caught moved the  basketball platoon all by himself in the  corner  again making plays for each other  refusing to  lay down and let go of the rope fighting  back into this ball game and  steve ballmer excited about the job that  his team's football  marcus morris has been a big part paul  george getting to the free-throw line  here in the third